hey guys I'm Ryan right now listen be
crazy there's a trailer out for a movie
called the theory of everything not
gonna lie I've been avoiding this
trailer simply because it doesn't sound
interesting to me haven't even don't
even know anything about it totally
fascinating I totally prejudged it and I
was like and it sound like this sounds
amazing I've never even heard this man
I've never heard of it either I just
know the title but I really judge the
hell out of it for some reason I don't
do that ever never let this for ticket
this particular movie made me go I don't
really care what you say I don't know
why you don't even know I know it's like
that's the theory of everything how are
you not at least a little bit intrigued
I don't know like like there's the
artists and I don't really care to watch
the artists well that takes a very
specific kind of audience whereas this
is everything well let's see all right
it's almost three minutes rate okay
course so big hurry come on get on what
they were seeking your whether you
voluntarily went on a PhD in physics
Oh cliff sighs ah
but cosmologists what's that I study the
marriage of space and time perfect
couple
[Music]
I'll never knows from where the next
great leap forward is going to come over
love
what if I first time to see what
happened at the beginning of time itself
way back the clock going back the car
keep going yet
it's called motor neuron disease life
expectancy is two years don't know just
abt other first numbers we've got you
don't realize what my is ahead this is
going to be a very heavy defeat but I
love him and he loves me we're going to
fight this illness together
look
okay so this back home at the beginning
of time
brilliant brilliant well done dot yes
pneumonia the only way were so bad be to
feeling the tracheal to me here we never
speak again
well my name is Stephen colic ended its
American is a problem it has been a
great joy to watch this man defy every
expectation both scientific and asthma
[Music]
there should be no boundaries to human
and desert however bad life may seem
well there is life there is hope
[Music]
ah you are really so like sweet I will
see this movie it's like a tugging at
your heart got a trailer man and I was
like huh I was I was cheered up a little
bit active my one problem is they ruined
that he eventually can't speak and he
has to talk through a computer
he ruined it yes because that is such a
big spoiler well it's yeah I mean like I
didn't know that oh you do not honestly
I'm really excited to see this because
like of course we know who he is like
what he's contributed and like he's of
just a brilliant mind like just me as a
person I know nothing about before
before that you know so it'll be cool
like a little geek at the beginnings me
as a person too
I don't know [ __ ] about Steven I okay
look I knew he's it a wheelchair I knew
all that stuff and I knew that he was
really smart he's so much about the
world and everything yet I never took
him for an emotional kind of guy and you
get a Z that like the exploration of
this like journey of it like he was
alive for quite a while mmm-hmm good for
him just to see like that's right this
guy's a human being
he's not just some brain with like I'm
interested to see like his emotional
that he had to go through not to mention
um the actor who portrays him I love him
if I'm not mistaken he's the one that is
very butter right Terry butter is Dana
Radcliffe Oh yep no I think he's the one
in uh yours oh nothing is yeah I think
it's like sunscreen eat on pause it yeah
that because Stephen Hawking saying this
one I don't think it's a musical it
could be it could be I think okay as
much as I love musicals I think that
would possibly ruin this movie possibly
just a little bit I think it would have
made the experience a lot more
interesting more emotional probably
sometimes a good song is all it takes
when I hear the theme song from Disney's
Aladdin the one that goes I can show you
the other things that's what is the
theme that's a theme song that's not a
theme song what is the song called whole
new world whole new world yeah every
time I hear it ball like a little [ __ ]
well if you guys are new to the channel
you okay I was really wrong about that
that looks great
yeah you can subscribe to the real
rejects and Alisa has a channel to a
YouTube channel relieve it or not yeah I
do
look all the lissa be crazy be crazy
[ __ ] is off the hook
fun things lots of challenges and stuff
[ __ ] things like that
Mario Bailey shout-out please
so how many people have gone up to me
like Mario hey how's your brother Luigi
yeah bang Princess Peach lately huh
writing your Yoshi around you know what
I mean you have a toad
Bowser come after you lately there's
gotta be more right I was koopa troopa
doing Wario come around lately
there's a plumber joke in there
somewhere you just have to reach for it
is that the joke
no no I'm waiting for you cuz I face it
reach for it then I imagine plumber
reaching for it and Mario's butt crack
is showing there you go Mario Bailey
there you go ha give me a New Super
Mario joke take it Emmanuel Perez is
really sad every night I pray to God
what is that maybe this time Ryan will
shout me out God but he never does so
now I am an atheist
thanks Ryan you made me lose faith in
everything why did I just somehow
envision all of this in a shrek is love
shrek is life video like this what
Justin folded in front of me right now
you know whatever do to Emanuel right
girl was asked down and bang him I'd be
the trick just jam it in there and you
want it just like the guy in the video
that's right Emanuel that's right I
don't mean maybe you're not gay I'm
sorry what does it matter you know
you're an atheist now I like being gay
is a sin anymore so come on it's not gay
if it's just for fun
ky didn't Kayden Carl Kaden shout me out
dawg love these vids yeah you do
Kaden Carl you know there is a guy named
Carl I was in a sixth grade and he was
in seventh grade huh now because I named
Carl that's great I'm still talking
though okay okay listen me interrupting
again okay you're in
you said sixth grade sixth grade and I
saw the movie 8 mile okay
and Carl was the only black guy in high
school so I assumed like the little
racist I was that he's probably the only
one who can freestyle so I rat battled
him and he did not rat back because he
did not know how to freestyle so I
technically won did he did he actually
accept her challenge I don't know
because if you didn't I technically
don't think you won cuz technically
there wasn't a challenge to win either
way I rapped and it was cool
Kaden Carl that is who he is now did you
know that I've been following you Carl
I know who you really are Kaden no I
know you really are that black man with
glasses and a shaved head I wonder if
you still look the same
I wonder if you're alive even well you
must be I mean you just commented in a
very dark hotend you have a dark mind
sometimes but not all the time you know
sometimes I think of just doing shrek is
love shrek is life stuff too it's akedan
Carl could we not I proved my dominance